what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special to offer and
I love to see it explode so that you can
help change the planet so to help you on
your journey today we're gonna talk
about seven ways to deal with failure as
an entrepreneur it's really hard and
you're gonna get a ton of failure along
the way not all your ideas are gonna
work out you're gonna fail and fail and
fail and failure eventually getting to
your point of success hopefully but
dealing with that failure can be really
tough until today I want to share with
you my seven ways and how to deal with
failure we number one is to change your
perspective one of the things that I've
learned from watching so many videos of
successful people across all different
fields some entrepreneurs athletes
musicians actors everyone when people
have had massive success in multiple
fields they all talk about failure as
not being final failure is just feedback
failures to be expected failure is part
of the process
failure is a stepping stone to success
fail your way to success failure failure
is a part of the learning process
success is moving from one failure to
the next to get past your failure you've
got to go through the failure success is
merely the hangover of failure you
should seek failures learn from those
mistakes and get smarter and I think too
many people fail the first time they
fail once like you try something that
doesn't work and you feel like I can't
do this I'm not meant to be an
entrepreneur I'm not meant to be an
actor I'm not meant to do that because
the first thing you did you failed that
expect this off like you will fail at
the beginning whatever you touch is
likely not gonna work the first time out
mostly because you don't know what
you're doing yet but you can pick it up
and learn really quickly and expect to
fail multiple times where if you find
the people who've had the most success
or you should the people who failed the
most if you look at my channel I failed
with tons of series I failed with more
series than most people try didn't even
ever get going with and so I learn from
those failures and thankfully not
everything failed some of the work then
we keep the winners and keep going and
keep
trying and so I think if you were to
watch videos or for me it's the videos
but if you're reading blog so just
surround yourself with people who have
failed a lot and had success to help
just shift that mindset that failure is
not this one-time thing and then you
suck as a human being that you're going
to fail it's okay it's normal it's part
of the process and the more you fail the
more you're gonna win if you are
surrounded by that and you start to
believe that you change your perspective
then you won't take it as personally and
you'll see it as a win to help you get
closer to where you want to go way
number two is to fail more the more you
try anything the better you get at it
right so the more you fail you're
building the muscle the more you fail
the more comfortable you get with it and
it's not that you always want to fail
you just want to be a constant failure
your entire life right there will be
successes along the way but if you fail
and it doesn't go well and then refuse
to even try anything in the future
that's the ultimate failure right and so
getting comfortable with failure not
being defined by failure not taking
failure so personally not taking
failures because this idea you have
didn't work that means that you suck as
a human being right to be able to detach
those two the more you fail the more you
try the more you get used to it the less
important the failure itself becomes and
more important achieving whatever the
goal is becomes and so just fail more
try more things fail again fail again
fail again and what you find is every
time you feel a little bit smarter a
little bit better it's not doing the
same thing the same way every single
time but you get a little bit better and
you start to see that the failure wasn't
as big and you've seen more results of
our results more results Angelo just
practicing in feeling and feeling better
consistently you'll build that muscle
and then it won't be as scary
[Music]
we number three is to practice being
uncomfortable a lot of times it's not
the failure itself that we're afraid of
it's the failure in front of other
people that we're afraid of we're afraid
of how our friends are going to judge us
our parents are going to judge us or how
people on social media are going to
judge us we're afraid of not the failure
but feeling in front of other people and
so the more you can lose that the more
you can practice being uncomfortable and
carrying less what other people think of
your successes or your failures or a
view in general then the less likely
you're gonna carry that failure around
and just feel like a terrible human
being if you'll worthless you will
release it and so I try to build a
muscle of whenever I feel uncomfortable
in something I'll step into the
discomfort filming here at the start
rights like these people walking by
there's people looking in the glass as
people wondering what's going on it was
nerve-racking at the start but because I
felt uncomfortable with it I had to do
it
I had to release it and now I could walk
in and doesn't matter used to it right
the first time I filmed in public same
thing I have to go out and do it you
know I got a got to release that
uncomfortableness and the first time I
did it I was walking in the street and
then somebody came close so I kind of
was quiet and then they left and then I
could continue to film and slowly slowly
slowly it got used to it where if
somebody's watching it doesn't matter
I'm okay with it I don't care about
their judgement so again the more you
step into uncomfortableness as a general
rule if you ever feel yourself playing
small because of somebody else's
potential opinion potential opinion even
know what their opinion is just their
potential opinion of you whenever you
can catch that a lot of times it's so
subconscious that you don't catch it
whenever you can catch it I encourage
you to step into it one last example
I've told a couple times was when I was
walking in the street and listening to
music and I'm dancing and doing you know
big movements and then I get to the
corner of a busy intersection and I
start I start dancing small then I stop
because there's people around me and I
was worried about their judgement and so
I didn't do anything
and when I caught it I realized I will
not play small because of their
potential judgment of me I'm not doing
anything that is gonna be harmful to
them right like I'm not going up in
their face and causing a scene I'm just
having fun on my own and so then I just
started dancing even bigger on the feet
corner because I needed to release that
fear and so getting used to being
uncomfortable when you feel the fear of
discomfort learn to jump into it build
the muscle and you'll feel failure a lot
less
[Music]
tip number four is to believe in
yourself failure is inevitable it's part
of life it's going to happen I have had
many failures in my life anywhere from
accidentally wearing a transparent dress
to work to failing add a decade-long
career and that was a big deal for me
I remember walking away from a career
that seems so lucrative and so promising
because I lost passion for it and people
around me started to question my sanity
they start questioning my
decision-making and they even turned
their backs on me and a lot of those
people I called my friends at that time
and I remember sitting at the edge of my
bed they give to myself this is what
life has become
I felt the lowest of lows because at
that time I measured my success based on
my finances and my social status and I
had neither all I saw was darkness
around me
but I had this tiny glimpse of hope and
this tiny glimpse of life and I believed
in myself I believed that I was going to
pull through and I did I invested all my
time into growing myself to developing
resilience and I grew a thicker skin and
just a few years later I was given an
opportunity to start a business with
Evan
that would have never happened unless I
did walk away from that career all those
years ago and that's a thing if you are
experiencing failure right now I know
how it feels this darkness all around
you but remember there's something
beautiful and amazing on the other side
of your failure and always always
believe in yourself we number five is
focused on the lesson learned if you can
find the positive and everything that
you're doing
it makes it a lot easier to do it again
if you fail and it didn't work out it's
easy to stay in that negative down zone
of I sock and this idea is never gonna
work and I'll never be an entrepreneur
and you know you just keep wallowing and
into the downward spike spike spike 'el
cycle spiral spiral and cyclist spike oh
we created new words here and you keep
spiraling downwards or if you can find
something positive from it okay well
that didn't work but I found this
I learned this about myself right the
famous Edison you know failed with the
light bulb I didn't fail 999 times I
found 990 ways 900 anyways not how not
to do it right like that famous quote if
you can learn a lesson from it if you
can understand that I learned something
from here then it's not a failure
because you learned because you grew
there was a benefit so trying to find
some kind of benefit from that failure
can bring the optimism back up and get
you back on the horse and go try and do
something else
[Music]
wait number six is have honest
conversations this is particularly for
the people who are afraid of feeling in
front of other people afraid of failing
and being judged whether that's your
friends the family the people around you
having an honest conversation you know
if you are afraid to start your business
because of what your mom might think or
what your best friend might think if it
doesn't work out then I would sit down
and try to have an honest conversation
say listen I really want to do this
thing I'm really scared I don't know if
it's gonna work out
it may not work out it's the scariest
thing you've ever done in my life and
the thing is preventing me from doing it
is because I don't want to fail in front
of you I'm worried about your judgment
and how you may see me as a son as a
friend as a brother as a whatever the
relationship is I just wanted to let you
know that this is a thing that's holding
me back now most people will hopefully
say well that's crazy like if you want
to do it you should do it I'm cheering
you on I'm gonna support you and I'd
love to see you how the success some
people won't you know some people will
say this is the stupidest idea ever what
are you talking about like don't go and
be an entrepreneur you're gonna fail for
sure yeah so you may not get the result
you want but at least for me at least
try noodley said there's if there's a
40% chance of it working out at least
being able to release that demon and get
their support and have them kind of
cheering you on and then when you do
fail because you will at some point they
have your back and their understanding
just in general for relationships any
kind of relationship communication is
important instead of just playing a
surface level game to really be
vulnerable and share the things that are
on our minds is super important so it
may not work out but I definitely
recommend having a conversation to at
least try to get that win
[Music]
and we number seven is just to decide to
live your life like at some point you
have to decide this is my life if I fail
it's okay I cannot continue to live my
parents life my friends life my cultures
life is what people are telling me to do
when you were growing up sure when
you're three years old you know you're
you're following your parents around you
you rely on them for food and to survive
but when you're picking age 16 18 25 30
like at some point you have to say this
is my life I'm gonna do what I want to
do and if it doesn't work out that's
okay but I'm not just gonna live my life
according to your expectations you know
like if you're worried about your mom's
opinion and you're 40 years old are you
still gonna live your life by her fifty
years old like how much of your life are
you going to waste living to other
people's expectations instead of living
your own life and it just comes from
deciding like I am deciding that I am
going to do this it may work it may not
work I'm doing it for me I don't care
about the opinions of the people around
me if you can't support me and me doing
the thing that I want to do then that's
a problem right then maybe you limit
your access to them or at least you
don't talk about those things with them
but it doesn't prevent you from moving
forward other people's expectations of
you should not prevent you from playing
the game you want to play because if
you're just playing up to other people's
expectations you're gonna be playing
small your entire life so it's just
deciding to live your life so those are
my tips on the seven ways to deal with
failure I made this video because I need
Keith asked me to there's a topic you'd
like me to cover in a future several
ways video check out the link in
description go there cast your vote have
your say and I just might do it I'd love
to know what did you think of the seven
tips which one resonated with you the
most you're gonna try and apply it in
your life or in your business somehow
leave it down in the comments below did
I miss an eight nine ten that you want
to add that you want to share with
believe nation add some value add some
love leave it down there in the comment
section below as well I also want to
give a quick shout out to MD McGill aka
Trident lion thank you so much for your
support of my book your one word picking
up a copy doing a review posting to
Twitter I really really really
appreciate it and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the book thank you guys again
for watching
I believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon